good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday here's
something we just saw which we brought
to you earlier vladimir zielinski the
president of ukraine of course gave an
interview recently that didn't get
enough attention in this country
zelinski needless to say is currently
engaged in a desperate fight for his
country his government his life and he
has been since the russian military
invaded ukraine nearly three weeks ago
so you can assume there's not a lot
zelensky thinks about at this point
apart from getting the russians off of
ukrainian soil
so last week zielinski floated the idea
of accepting so-called ukrainian
neutrality agreeing not to join nato in
exchange for that he would get a russian
withdrawal from ukraine
there's nothing inherently controversial
about zielinski's idea ukraine was not
on the cusp of joining nato anyway nato
officials have long said they don't want
ukraine to join it's not clear whose
interest would be served by ukraine
joining nato so if accepting the status
quo going with the way things already
were and were always going to be if
doing that convinces putin to stop
killing ukrainians and spares ukraine
from total and complete destruction
maybe it's not a crazy idea maybe
zelensky is on to something he certainly
thought about it a lot maybe we ought to
congratulate zielinski for acting wisely
on behalf of the country he leads this
could be a win for him and for the
entire world
probably not a lot of american media
outlets will describe it that way
however indeed by mentioning nato
a topic that is completely off limits in
american media zelinski may have gone
too far
daily in every possible venue we are
told that nato is paradoxically both of
its central importance to the united
states and at the same time irrelevant
to what happens in eastern europe
so years of talk about expanding nato
into ukraine
and we've watched those happen in public
that had nothing whatsoever to do with
russia invading ukraine nothing at all
that's what they tell us putin invaded
ukraine because
he's bad end of conversation and anyone
who says otherwise anyone who suggests
there might be a way out of this
disaster short of total war anyone who
says that is immediately denounced as a
tool of russian propaganda so what does
that mean it means that by acknowledging
that nato expansion is what putin seems
to care about most
zielenski is by definition at least in
this country repeating russian talking
points
that would make the president of ukraine
a putin collaborator
sound insane well then you can still
think clearly but that's the state of
play how do we know this
let's just say we've lived it
we've made the point repeatedly that
forcing ukraine into nato will in no way
serve the interests of the united states
and in fact could hurt us here in ways
from which we will never recover
and by the way talking about it doesn't
seem to have helped ukraine either
for saying that and that's all we've
said
here's the reaction we've received and
this is just a small selection we could
do a full hour on it but
here's a clip what seems to be almost
the putin wing of the republican party
uh which which to be fair is not highly
not prevalent much on capitol hill but
we've seen tucker carlson uh you know
the
basically repeat russian propaganda
night after night what the hell is going
on well first of all before they fell in
love with putin they fell in love with
orban and hungary
make america great again man let's make
america more like hungary and the most
popular republican broadcaster in
america tucker carlson are both
unabashed fans of putin and there are
very few republicans out there like mitt
romney or liz cheney who have the
courage to call them out this is a
disgrace
how anybody in this country
which loves freedom
can side with vladimir putin
which is an oppressor a dictator he
kills people
he
he imprisons his political opponents uh
he has been an adversary of america at
every
chance he's had it's unthinkable to be
it's it's almost treasonous
oh almost treasonous siding with putin
who's signing putin i haven't seen
anybody do that i've seen a few people
try to side with the united states and
that says mitt romney a man who got four
deferments to keep himself out of the
vietnam war that
is almost treasonous
what's so interesting we don't want to
pick on mitt romney here it's too easy
but it does seem like if you take a step
back the very same people who spent the
last say two years telling us that this
country
our country is inherently sinful
and racist and disgusting
and born in iniquity
those same people the ones who lecture
you about how there's something
inherently wrong with you if you live
here were born here those same people
have been the very quickest the very
first to whip around
and accuse anyone who wants to save the
united states from yet another pointless
war a war that they would never fight in
and or their children
accuse those people of being unpatriotic
you don't love america enough
says the man who thinks america is
racist
how does that work exactly we're not
sure but in case you've forgotten here's
the very same mitt romney marching with
the very same people who told us that
this is a white supremacist hell hole
and by the way we've got to do away with
the nuclear family that's never done
anybody any good here he is
a way to end violence
and brutality and to make sure that
people understand that black lives
matter
so okay it's just mitt romney
never a genius obviously deep in the
grip of some late life crisis licking
his wounds for being beaten by obama in
2012 okay
but it's not just mitt romney
imagine how you would feel if you were a
business owner in kenosha or minneapolis
or atlanta or louisville
if you were someone who i don't know
used to go to saint john's church in
washington dc or someone who works in
the federal courthouse in portland
oregon before blm torched all of it
you're long accustomed to knowing that
your leaders don't really care about you
but when they reveal that they actively
hate you
that's hard to take
so of course mitt romney is debasing
himself degrading himself in order to be
liked in washington yeah we've seen that
of course but it's deeper than that
needless to say the people mitt romney
wants to like him his new masters were
not satisfied with him marching with blm
or denouncing his critics as almost
treasonous they want more
they won't be satisfied until every
republican in the u.s senate is wholly
indistinguishable from chris hayes and
they're getting pretty close
on sunday yesterday
mitt romney edged a little closer
here's what he wrote to tulsi gabbard
now tulsi gabbard is a former member of
congress who currently serves as
lieutenant colonel in the u.s army
reserve and unlike mitt romney has been
deployed quote tulsi gabbard is
parroting false russian propaganda her
treasonous lies
may well cost lives
treasonous lies
have cost lives potentially so you're
betraying your country and committing
murder
so what exactly did tulsi gabbard do did
she call for a violent overthrow of the
united states government did she come
out and pledge allegiance to putin
did she get a cyrillic tattoo on her
neck no she didn't
what she said is we have a problem
here's how we know she cited publicly
available information and said we should
probably deal with that problem
but in case here we have mitt romney who
was a consultant for god's sakes
accusing someone who's been in the army
for nearly two decades of treason
people didn't use to talk that way
treason is a death penalty offense
it's absurd on its face
but if you watch the video that got mitt
romney to call a fellow american
treasonous and suggest she was
committing murder
it really makes your head spin
here's what tulsi gabbard actually said
that made mitt romney accuse her of
betraying her own country watch
here are the undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the u.s government these
bio labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities even in the best of
circumstances could easily be
compromised and release these deadly
pathogens
yeah she hates our country because she's
worried that a pathogen might escape
from a biolab and hurt people
there's no recent precedent for that so
she's clearly listening to alex jones
too much and she's treason us actually
everything that tulsi gabbard said as
you know is true it's not a republican
issue it's not a democrat issue it's a
factual issue and even in war truth is a
defense in fact it's the only defense is
it true and in a free country you can
speak the truth
that right can never be taken away or
else it's not a free country but by the
way since we're speaking of facts the
director of the u.s cooperative threat
reduction program a man who would know a
man called robert pope has confirmed
that scientists are keeping soviet-era
pathogens for research purposes in
ukraine
they told us they were destroying them
they should have destroyed them but they
haven't
what could go wrong in an active war
zone and they knew that those pathogens
existed and were being
experimented upon researched
and they didn't secure them before the
russians invaded though they knew the
russian invasion was coming because they
told us
and then tori newland the under
secretary of state who oversees this
disaster testified under oath that yes
russian forces might seize those bio
labs in ukraine and we should all be
very worried about that possibility over
the weekend cbs news reported that
pentagon officials have confirmed that
these biolabs in ukraine are in fact
conducting research on anthrax and other
quote deadly pathogens pentagon official
i talked to you this morning said there
is no
movement of chemical weapons
into ukraine at least they're not seeing
the signs of it the concern is that the
russians will seize one of these
biomedical research facilities that
ukraine has where they do research on
deadly pathogens like botulism and
anthrax
seize one of those facilities
weaponize the pathogen and then blame it
on ukraine and the us because the u.s
has been providing support for some of
the research being done in those
facilities
okay so we're a little confused about
what all the hyperventilating is about
now you just heard cbs say and you've
heard many say that russia may seize
these biological agents in ukraine and
use them against the ukrainians and who
knows who else
now you would pause and think well wait
a second if these are soviet aero
weapons then presumably
the soviets now called the russian
government probably have their own so
why would they want to see stuff they
already have it doesn't actually make a
lot of sense but whatever you'll notice
that the reporter you just saw at the
beginning of the clip
admits
that these pathogens are in ukraine
they're doing research on botulism and
anthrax so any reasonable person would
be concerned by that because there's a
war going on and by the way why were
they funding this in ukraine in the
first place but that's really a
secondary question maybe we can get to
the bottom of that when the war's over
but tulsi gabbard addressed and only
addressed the danger that innocent
people could die
because these weapons apparently these
pathogens these agents exist in ukraine
she didn't blame it on russia she didn't
blame anybody she just said this is a
thing
unsecured bio weapons in a war zone are
a bad idea that's not reasonable now
that's treason
reason isn't part of the way people are
thinking now
everybody in leadership has completely
lost the ability to think beyond the
next tweet who is thinking about
tomorrow or next month or 20 years from
now not one person
and anyone who tries is an agent of
putin
now to a story of russian disinformation
that has been quickly embraced and
amplified by some in america's
right-wing media when state department
under secretary victoria newland
confirmed this week that there was bio
research going on in ukraine critics say
that tucker carlson of fox news took
those remarks out of context uh now you
see the chinese government kind of
openly
repeating russian propaganda
for example about the supposed american
bio labs
in ukraine
this russian misinformation
about bio labs in ukraine people on the
trump right who are actually parroting
russian propaganda every day and every
night
these supposed bio labs well the us
government says they have bio labs and
told us under oath that they're worried
about the contents of these bio labs
which they failed to secure
might get into the wrong hands but it's
right-wing putinite propaganda
we're taking newlin's remarks out of
context okay what what's the right
context we asked no one told us
robert pope's remarks were they take out
of context too
this is insane there's a problem
before we even assign blame to the
problem it might be worth thinking
through how to fix the problem
but no
anyone who mentions it should shut
up and not just shut up
be shut up by force if necessary with
jail time
now we're going to do something we
almost never do we're going to play you
a clip
from the view which is now calling for
department of justice investigation into
this show and chelsea gabbard watch what
tucker carlson parrots evernight on fox
news what tulsi gabbard is spreading is
actually helping putin get away with
criminal acts against innocent ukrainian
civilians and i think doj in the same
way that it is uh setting up a task
force to investigate oligarchs should
look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
that's being if you are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
in fact i remember
when tulsi gabbard and i even hate that
we're discussing it because i think to
myself who is this woman how do you not
call out something that is repeating
false russian propaganda that has been
brought down they used to arrest people
for doing stuff like this
really they used to arrest people for
saying stuff like this hmm when did they
arrest people for saying stuff like this
and who is they exactly
well the former karen elaine johnson
didn't tell us she kept it vague because
that way it's a lot more threatening and
maybe you will shut up and again we
hesitate to show clips from that show
it's an iq killer but we're making an
exception tonight because the view is
not alone a lot of people sound like
this and it's one of these processes
where it sounds insanely for sure i
can't believe they said that
and then over time what sounded crazy
the first time you heard it sounds a
little more normal and then three weeks
into the war it sounds like probably
pretty necessary
keith oberman is always at the cutting
edge of things like this he was watching
the view today doesn't have a lot else
to do and he responded to that segment
by writing this on twitter they us are
russian assets and there is a war
there's a case for detaining them
militarily
trials are a sign of good faith and
patience on the part of democracy
so we're at war with russia we must send
you to the gulag because freedom
because a democracy the one thing
democracies have patience for
is dissenting views from its own
citizens particularly citizens who
sincerely hope and pray for the best for
their own country those people must be
imprisoned militarily
that's what he's saying
and no one's disagreeing
all of permanent washington every
orifice of the national media all fully
aligned to push a single message
what was the last time that happened
ought to make you nervous
senator rob portman of ohio who's
leaving thankfully he said the other day
that the current moment is the most
united this country has been since 9 11.
well he's right in one way it's
certainly united the united states
congress
as of this afternoon nine out of the
last 10 tweets that rob portman sent
have been about ukraine
oh
not a single tweet about the fact you're
getting poorer by the day try to fill up
your car on amazon last night a single
jar of organic peanut butter cost 15
bucks that's just one product
on retailer renowned for offering the
cheapest possible 15 bucks for a jar of
peanut butter spread that across the
entire grocery store and that's what
you're looking at
is that gonna
help with the fentanyl
killings that are going on right now
hundred thousand people die last year no
rob portman doesn't care what he cares
about is ukraine and he shares that
concern with lindsey graham and chuck
schumer and nancy pelosi and of course
liz cheney so they are unified
but what's so interesting if this is
such a unifying moment
then why was their first instinct to
denounce fellow americans as traitors
and call for them to be imprisoned
really unifying
they don't care about ukraine a lot of
these people any more than they cared
about george floyd
they used tragedy
george floyd's death the tragic invasion
of ukraine for domestic political
purposes this is unleashed something
really dark in the united states
in order to make wise decisions you have
to be rational
thoughtful
forward thinking and calm
and they're the opposite of all of those
things
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else